so just to give some introductions first
of all as Adam mentioned I consulted and
consulting for 15 years and various
guises lots of different clients small
clients big clients I'm one of the
cofounders of the PI data London
community that we have here we started
in six years ago with our first
conference and our meetup series the
meetup has grown too we just shy of
10,000 members now with 200 people
coming to our monthly meetups free beer
free pizza high-quality data science
talks and then the pub afterwards you're
all very welcome and I encourage you to
come along I'm also an author of
high-performance Python without Riley
that book is 5 years old now in Python
2.7 Python 2.7 is about to be deprecated
this year so my co-author and I are
working on the second edition
that'll be released next year we do have
copies at the current Edition for
signing tomorrow it's perfectly correct
except for Python 2.7 so on your print
statement you have to put round brackets
otherwise it's all correct and there's
obviously technology we've missed in the
last 5 years so it needs updating but if
you'd like to learn about high
performance which is not the subject of
today's tutorial please come and queue
up for one of those and there's a
limited set that I Riley have kindly
sent us I'm also a Pluralsight author
I've got out one video course up there
happy to talk about that if you're
interested in plurals try to hear
sponsoring this weekend so I do a couple
of things I help companies like the ones
you saw before and build up their data
science plans and execute on them I've
been doing this for 15 years I've gone
from developing IP to more frequently
helping teams to develop their own IP
now on one of the ways that I deal with
that is to train about a couple of
public courses what we're going to cover
here is not from a public course but I
really care about my training approach
so I'm a little bit nervous about giving
a course that I haven't even finished
yet so I'm after your feedback after
this one I'm very much like some
feedback on how it's set up what you
learned from it what problems you came
in with on whether this addressed some
of your problems requirements today it's
a standard PI data
environment if you're using anaconda
that's brilliant you'll have it all
already we're using pandas Seabourn and
a jupiter notebook one notebook that
you've already cloned from the from the
github link and one data file which is
open data and you can do a condor
install Seabourn pandas and Jupiter I
think without commas someone tell me
without commas yeah I should have tried
that in the slides condor install anyway
those three and you'll have the
environment but you should have that
already if you've got an anaconda
environment so I'm assuming that you
know some pandas already you want to
learn about time series particularly
some manipulation and the visualization
right let's get going so first of all
can you all see the notebook screen so
is that big enough to see and those
lights are really bright so if you want
it I'm very happy to answer questions
wave at me and I brilliant thank you
very much that's that's easier all right
you can wave me you can shout out loud
I'm very happy to have discussions I
don't believe we're gonna get to the end
of this notebook depends upon how well
we do with the the few questions that
arise during it and I'm going to ask you
questions and I'd like your feedback on
the things that you're seeing it'll be
much easier for you if you're rendering
it locally because then you can have a
look at the graphs that we're drawing
they may not be super clear on the lower
resolution up here and if your machine
turn to your neighbor and share with
their machine and you'll see lots of
pretty pictures so who has done
date/time manipulation in pandas before
okay some of you have how many of you
use pandas at least a couple of times a
month okay how many of you have not used
pandas in the last few months okay
only a couple of you good right I
apologize you're going to may struggle a
little bit because I'm not introducing
pandas here
the notebook lumps completely as it is
and you'll pick up pandas as we go
through it but I'm not introducing the
basic two pandas just the basics of
visualization and time series but that
suits almost all of you in the room so
it's brilliant we're on the right page
so I've imported pandas as PD the the
normal way to import Anders we can make
date/time objects really easily inside
pandas because it has some good string
processing routines to make date objects
and then we can do things with those
data objects particularly we can make
some time series so dates at a certain
regular frequency using some existing
data that's what we're going to use here
some German open data for utilities
solar and wind power and energy
consumption and then look at those over
a number of years and look for patterns
in that data set but first of all we
need to make some dates times and see
how they work so super easy we just do a
to date time so pandas to date time give
it a string years months days maybe a
time and it creates an internal
timestamp object so we have a regular
object and then we can create lots of
these and we can vary them we can use
Delta's so it can take two timestamps
and take a difference and we can do
things to those differences so we have a
very standard and easy to use interface
anyone who's done date/time manipulation
in regular Python with their date/time
objects knows that things are grey until
they become not great and they get weird
and when they become weird they get
really hard to debug and as soon as you
introduce time setting time zones things
get even weirder has anyone had fun
mixing time zones and non time zone data
before and by fun I mean put your hand
up and groan okay it's always a payment
back side and so pandas deals with a lot
of this for us so we can make date times
just off of dates as well and we can do
this years and years and months and
alike we can add time so information and
here I'm using a standard ISO 8601 date
format date times of one of those
annoying things in the world where
everybody feels compelled to create
their own new format for a thing which
looks a little bit like the other
standards but it's a bit different again
so we have an N plus one standard going
on there's an ISO 8601 standard just
your life will be so much easier if you
use it please don't decide to be
slightly American or slightly European
or slightly something else or save a
couple of bite to make it bit smaller or
lose the minuses or the spaces or the
colons just to save some characters in
your logging it's a really bad idea it's
just much easier to express things in
ISO 8601 every part on the planet will
understand it there'll be no more
confusion and we're not constrained by
space like we were 30 years ago so just
write out long form dates your life will
be so much easier this Davis it doesn't
use ISO 8601 but it parses okay anyway
because pen this is pretty good at
picking up different date times so just
a few more examples we can create one
off of a string and force UTC as a time
zone or any other time zone that we want
in there UTC is another standard we can
pass in that's month month day day
format and we can flick that around with
a day first flag so depending on whether
you're American or European you put days
and months before each other in
different ways yep
zoom in like that all right I may okay
we'll see how we go can you see it on
your screen ah okay
I'll see how we go with the graphs they
may not fit on the screen I might have
to zoom in and out but that's fine just
remind me we can do that and we can make
ranges as well and there's a very
convenient date range operator here I'm
saying from 2018 January the first I'd
like 10 items at a frequency of days
single days so I get 2018 Oh 101 201 10
so I get ten days worse and I can do
this hourly in fact there are some rules
down below I can do daily business daily
such a five-day cycle weekly monthly
quarterly hourly by the minute anything
you want in between there for any length
and so that's it's really powerful for
coming up with a structured range so if
for example you've got a time series log
of stuff you've got a part of numbers
but no date range associated with them
you can add that date range and then
merge the data together
I don't know good question but no I
don't know pandas is pretty good for all
of its business rule handling because it
was designed by where's McKinney who was
a quant at the time and works around the
chrome space still so it's got very good
business day rule handling and time zone
handling for international dates but I
don't know about some specific holiday
things all right and so there's some Oh
couple more examples of time deltas this
time so we can make dates so dates and
specific days or hours but we it may
want Delta ranges as well so here I want
I'm gonna start with one day and I want
to end at five days and I want five
periods
that'd be five one day periods and it
creates these time Delta's so I could
start with a date and then say apply the
deltas to it and calculate the dates
that come out of it so I start with a
specific date and I've got a lump of
data and I want this stuff to be
expressed monthly and it will have to
start creating those monthly items for
me and I've got days I've got one day in
24 hour periods hourly and of course we
get hours out the other side it's very
flexible so just the check at this stage
those of you that are following along
does anyone have any problems running
the notebook on your machine or are you
happy that you've got it running
hands up if there's any problems we're
all good brilliant so we're gonna load
in some open open utilities data for
green energy production from Germany
it's about 10 years worth of data up
until 26 2018 I think we'll see that
graphed out shortly the link for the
data was up at the top of the notebook
if you wanna go and explore and there's
much more data available lots of data in
fact from a big European project
aggregating it together this is a slice
brought together by somebody else that
we've taken here so I'm guessing
everyone's seen read CSV before just one
of
standard methods for loading in CSV data
so comma separated value data and it's a
pretty small file so we've got four
thousand three hundred rows and five
columns worth of data we can take the
head of that and then we get a date
which in this case has been correctly
interpreted as a date object sometimes
you load in dates and their
representative strings Panthers doesn't
recognize that it prints out during head
as what appears to be a date but
actually it's just the string and you
start to do time series manipulation and
then you find out they don't know I've
just got a stream like any other string
a list of names and then you have to do
a little bit of conversion it's very
easy to do the conversion but it's
always good to check and we'll check
that in just a moment you can see that
we've got our consumption so this is
people using power and then the
generation of wind solar and the
combination of wind and solar and at the
beginning of the data set those data
items are missing their nan not a
numbers and at the end of the data set
they're all filled in so we go from 2006
to 2017 early in the data sets we're
either not recording or not generating
those green power sources I guess not
recording and then by the end it's all
being recorded so we can look at the D
types we've got an object for the date
and then the rest of em represented as
float64 numbers nice and easy so then we
can use set index so he refused set
index takes an arbitrary column and
assigned it to the index so that we can
start getting data from getting subsets
of data by specifying not row numbers
not the 100 to the 200 but a date range
and we can specify that date range by
just typing out a date range and panners
we'll figure out what indexing we're
after so here we've set the beginning of
that data set 2006 Oh 101 with our
consumption data if we call up that
index item we see that we've got a
series represented as an index object it
has a name right at the bottom called
date so date with a big D so that name
is a property you can ask the index for
its name and it will tell you which
column it came from but they column
4,000 items in it and there's a shortcut
method generating the same thing
we've done this we don't really care so
let's have a look at this one so now we
want to make up some new columns has
anyone not made up columns of data by
manipulating existing columns before
couple of you
so in pandas you can make new columns
new data frame by manipulating it
existing columns I mean that's that's
that's the reason we've got pandas it
makes it really easy to generate new
columns not just add columns some
external sources and add them into a
data frame but take something that's
there and transform it maybe combine it
with other columns that generate new
columns when we have there are certain
column types that let us do extra
transformations so with a string column
a column containing textual data you can
do things like call the standard Python
string functions so you can say for this
column drop into the string mode and
pull up the length of the call of the
electro the length of the items in this
column or for every item see which ones
are start with the character a or do a
find operation so you can do all the
string manipulation with date/time
columns we can run through all of the
data so here I'm going to say that first
row I'm going to make a new column
called a year where I take the index and
I extract from that date time object
just the year so I don't want the whole
date time I just from the year so it
pulls out the year from that composite
date time object then we do the same for
the month we can ask for the weekday
name this is a newer pandas feature
there was an old synonymous function
synonymous attributes not a function it
didn't have round brackets on the end
that's been deprecated and a name
replaces it so if you've ever gone out
the I figure out what the old one was
called the name so that's the string
representation of a day and a date/time
object before you'll find that's been
updated in pandas recently so we can
call index dot day name when we get the
name out Monday Tuesday Wednesday we can
pull out the weekday just as a number so
a numeric indicator 0 through 6 its
weekend I can say is that the weekday in
the set is in the set of 5 comma 6 0 is
Monday 5 6 Saturday and some
and that gives me a binary indicator so
I can generate some new features for
those of you doing machine learning you
know that generating new features is
absolutely critical for any of our work
anyone telling a visual story you
probably want to make a nice visual
story by adding new features and then
slicing your data to demonstrate points
of interest and so things like the is in
asset operator really really nice
shortcuts so what do we have now so
we've gone from a couple of columns to
this rich data set we can see the
weekday name and the weekday next to it
so they're tied one to one sixties or
Sundays or Mondays of zeros Sunday is a
weekend Monday is not a weekend and 2006
first month mashing up to the date index
and we've had a look at those already
fine so those of you that have done date
for analysis for any amount of time or
no and I have a very very strong and
heartfelt position on this your data
lies to you and it generally tries to
trip you up and perhaps it's trying to
get you fired it's been trying to get me
fired for a decade and a half and I
resist those attempts I resist those
attempts by printing out lots of things
we get to graphing to make sure it all
makes sense but I count things at the
beginning just to make sure that things
feel sane so the value counts function
is brilliant if I had a really weird
distribution of data in my time series
set I would not expect the value counts
to give me an equal number of Monday's
through some days but here we get an
equal number there's one extra Sunday so
the day the data set has one additional
working day in it than might otherwise
be expected but it's not the case that
we have a surfeit of Mondays through
Fridays and hardly any Saturdays or
Sundays that would indicate that we'd
lost data logging on weekends perhaps
suggesting a systemic error somewhere in
the data collection stage which I really
want to know about if I'm going to start
to do some analysis yeah we've got a
really nice clean consistent data set
and described as a very standard way of
looking at the numerical characteristics
of our data set one of the flaws are
described but not Florence is that it
can't be done
is that we can't calculate these
statistics for string columns so some of
our data set now is string columns we
can't do anything with that but for the
numeric columns we can so for
consumption we can see that we've got
four thousand three hundred and eighty
three items brilliant for wind that's
the count first row for wind two
thousand nine hundred and twenty that's
because about a third to a half on
missing data so it's our first
indication that we're missing a bunch of
data separate to the other indication
that we had earlier on so maybe this
tells us we need to go and look into our
day-to and backfill if we want to do
some more analysis at least we've got a
flag that something's a bit up the
minimum and maximum good things there's
sensible things to go and check as well
I mean a consumption that is positive
that's pretty good we don't get a
negative consumption that might suggest
something really weird has gone on in
our logging the fact that the the ranges
say the the minimum for wind and solar
is five and 1.9 as opposed to a
consumption of 800 that's kind of
different there's different by orders of
magnitude that might mean that something
is up it might mean that our units are
unspecified and we need to go and
specify them or it might just mean that
early in the days of logging this power
generation not much was generating so
these numbers are sensibly low but at
least we get a clue to go and look into
this I went for a year we can see with
describe we've got minimum 2006 maximum
2017 so we've got a same data set and
our months ranged in 1 and 12 so again
just a sense check those things look
pretty sensible so we can do indexing
and indexing is incredibly important of
course into our regular data when you
get to date time data it becomes a bit
non-obvious how you do your indexing but
you can just use the lock function hands
up if you use lock normally Oh
for those who don't use lock what might
else what else might you be using to
index into your data I'm curious
I look okay yep so lock and I look we'll
come to our look in a second there's the
apt operator anyone using the i-x
operator that's the one that's
deprecated absolutely IX is bad IX does
everything and that's great if the
things you're indexing into have a
unique way of indexing into them if
you've got a numeric column and use IX
it might do positional based indexing
with the number or it might look for the
thing that is named by that've if your
indices starts ten to a hundred ten
might mean the thing that's ten sin or
ten the index which is the first item in
the index IX plus all of those things
does different things depending on what
it's given that was the old way of
indexing that can get you fired because
you can make really bad mistakes with
that so you should never use it it's
been deprecated and it warns you that
it's been deprecated and so we use lock
and I lock I lock is the integer
location go to this ice location just by
counting through and lock says look this
thing up based on the label I've given
it here I can say I want the item at 220
1708 10 and then bang we get our series
item out that's that row of data another
caveat in Python our indexing is always
from this thing so from say the zero
thing up to ten will be zero through
nine inclusive date time indexing in
pandas is inclusive of both boundaries
not inclusive and exclusive like in the
rest of Python I don't understand this
it has caught me out in the past it will
catch you out just be very aware of this
if we do this we will see that we get 20
21 and 22 so three items not the usual
two that we would get I don't know why I
wish I knew why it's different to the
rest of Python just be aware of it we
can also do partial matching so I can
say 2012 February and then don't give it
any days and then I get to 30 or days
worth of data back for all of February
in that year so that's really nice to
get partial matching and that comes for
free let's do a bit of visualizing who's
used Seaborn before some of you okay
good
so Seaborn builds on top of matplotlib
and it gives us some richer graphing and
richer statistical summarizations and
were going to cover a bunch of those in
this tutorial so first of all we can
take this consumption data and plot it
here which is that a line width 0.5 to
make the lines quite thin because
there's a lot of data you can see that
by default map what live has which is
underneath the Seabourn has picked a
sensible date time for matter there's
lots of data over a decade's worth of
date times so it's picked the year for
matter and so we get on the x-axis 2006
2008 2010 going across we get our
consumption between roughly a thousand
and 1600 and then we see some patterns
so uh you know this one's obvious but
someone shout out what's the pattern
that's going on here so yeah so winter
the cold months we use more energy
Germans use more energy but we all use
more energy in there in the cold months
and I don't know what how the energy is
consumed specifically there are other
data sets where they break down all
sorts of interesting usage
characteristics this is just consumption
of energy of electrical energy but yeah
in winter we use more and in summer we
use less and we see this nice cyclical
pattern every year do we use the same
amount every year over that 10 year
range
don't be so cool here no we don't it
goes up and down a bit we don't know why
that is I do have a question for you
later about some of this and which we'll
look at so what if we look at these that
I'm just going to zoom out and then I'm
zoom back in for the gentleman here
we've got a bit of code that generates
three plots for the three major factors
that we have here one for consumption
and then we've got solar generation
which starts later many nouns there
because earlier either wasn't generated
almost locked and then wind which also
is we have more of it than solar but
less than for the consumption can you
tell me something you see in this data
set there's a couple of things we can
see here give me some feedback and don't
be shy absolutely right yeah so first
solar we see a nice clear peak and then
it drops off in winter and when it drops
off in winter the amount of power being
generated by solar the rain seems to be
quite small but in the summer time the
range is quite big and quite pronounced
that's kind of interesting and so also
we see an inclining generation of solar
over the years what do we see with wind
right so we see a similar increase in
the trend and but yes that that change
invariance is really kind of interesting
so we we see those Peaks there there and
but in the winter the minimus aren't so
small so in the winter greater get lots
of wind or actually that that's the
other thing I think here the cycles are
at have a counterpoint to the solar
generation it's clearer when we look at
this later in the winter it's windier we
get more vineyard in the winter and in
the summer it's less windy because the
weather's nicer so actually it's a their
the the two cycles are out of sync with
each other and the variance is much
higher so it's a it's harder to see that
signal will clear some of that up in a
bit what do we see with the consumption
each data point is a day
Yeah right well we see two patterns and
we can hypothesize and we will test that
they are weekdays and weekends yes we
see two patterns absolutely right yeah
and we haven't normalized the axes here
so consumption is up to 1600 solar up to
about 200 and wind up to 800 and so
really solar looks really clean and kind
of cool but actually it's really tiny
relative to everything else and we'll
normalize it a bit later on as well good
spot so what pattern do we see here so
let's what are we doing first of all
we're doing something interesting with
the lock operator so we're asking look
to find everything in 2017 search 365
days with a data in 2017 and also just
the consumption columns are just one
column rather than all the columns and
then we're plotting it and so we can see
some interesting we believe what we
patterns and I would like you to
interpret these patterns for me and
there's a couple of patterns in here so
what do you see I don't think there's
the obvious one that consumption in
summer is lower than consumption in
winter sure looks like a weekly pattern
absolutely looks like a seven-day window
we see there it's not a super-clean
weekly pattern if it is there's
certainly some interesting bits in there
I'm not entirely sure where they I've
got a hypothesis from entirely sure
that's a crash at the end of the year
we're just turns all the lights off and
goes home there's a massive crash around
Christmas time so presumably that's work
place is shutting down and then people
having holidays and so we're looking
perhaps it's a personal consumption
rather than an industrial consumption at
that period I don't know if that's true
I haven't dug further into the data to
see that well we we would look at this
and think hey there's something
interesting going on in here right there
so there's some odd patterns in here
it's not a clean cyclical annual shape
there's more to
there's some other layers going on that
we need to pull out who say that I can't
see you sorry Arthur
Sagan ah right and so that's what I
think we see with that and I've got a
question for this coming up
yeah and I'm assuming they're bank
holidays or holidays or something like
that but I don't know the German
calendar I did check some of it I don't
know all of it
so is your first mini exercise so just
above you've got the guts of the code
that you need for this so if you've run
it to here if you haven't run into here
just do run also as above and it'll run
you to this point
I'd like for 2017 not just consumption
that we have before but consumption and
months to pull out a subset of that data
so not draw it straight away we just
pull out for 2017 the consumption and
month figures and then group by and I'm
presuming you've all done group buys
before we just use the group by function
and I'll work with you in a moment
use the group by function on month and
then that will give us and then what I
said it then I want the mean so take the
mean of that group so we want the 2017
grouped by months mean consumption for
the average consumption by the month and
then if you're very keen you can either
try some of the other functions from
group I so not just mean but some median
standard deviation variance and we can
try to draw as well I'll give you two
minutes just to put that together and
try some of those variants
so I'll start to solve this up on screen
so first of all I'm going to extend the
use of lock to take the 2017 data and
rather than just getting consumption as
a single pair of quotes I've put it in a
list consumption and months so I want
the pair of columns I want a data frame
back not a series and then once I've got
a data frame I can apply group by to it
the group by on a series of making no
sense there's nothing to group there's
no additional columns but a data frame
of at least two columns I can do a group
by so now I can do group by and when I
do a group by by itself or whether they
get wrong there or group on a thing I
have to tell it what to group on so
group on my monthly column then I get
this really inscrutable object group
buyers are a complete pain in the
backside as far as I'm concerned because
they've really hard to diagnose
particular if you're grouping by on
several different things they're trying
to do more complicated things you just
get this object that you can't do
anything with it so right pain but if
you're just grouping on a single thing
and you've got one other column and you
know that it's all numbers you the
basics should just work so here I can do
a mean and then I should get back for my
toe of months my toe of means sitting on
having any trouble with that the rest of
the exercise or the rest of the material
is not dependent upon this so we can
skip over it but if you're doing it you
want to do it I'd rather you've got it
is that working for everyone yeah and a
bunch of you have done group bys before
and you know this you're not surprised
by it those of you doing it for the
first time might take a moment to work
it through
it's worth noting that with that group
by I could have made I could have got a
number of columns so I could have had
consumption along with months along with
wind along with solar and then grouped
by months and then done the mean and
then consumption solar wind would have
all been mean I would have had three
columns of results rather than just the
current one you get the all 10 years but
the data yeah which will be fine we just
smudged the months over 2017 2016 2015
all of the January's merged together and
that's fine we probably get a more
robust result for consumption because we
saw earlier it looked like a fairly
stable distribution the population of
Germany is not changing significantly in
this time window so the energy usage
hasn't changed drastically now we get
we're getting this series back brilliant
it's indexed 1 to 12 great we can see
that its index by months but it's a bit
hard to see
we'd like to visualize this so what can
we do to visualize it what's the easiest
thing we can do
plot right if I just put plot on the end
then I should get that back and so now
from months 1 through 12 so January
through December I get my mean
consumption and we see accepting that
the the y-axis range hasn't been
normalized from 0 up to a large number
but we still see the trend in the data
summer months lower usage on average and
then winter months higher usage around
fridge except for that's kind of strange
quirk in December where less is used I
presume that's holiday related I don't
know
did anyone have any difficulty with that
that they any questions that we should
address does anyone have any questions
in general at this stage about dates
time manipulation and summary statistics
with group buyers no all good okie-doke
so let's dig in a bit and look at some
daily behavior
so here I've used lock taking out
January and February inclusive that
slightly odd non-standard inclusive
range behavior in pandas with dates in
regular price did you expect to get
January back with this but not February
in panda forget January and February and
we're calling out the consumption column
just by itself and then inside the plot
function we're saying we use circles for
the markers so they become more visible
points otherwise we just get lines with
no apparent breaks and then part from
the angular change that you would see
the circles make those days really
obvious the circles also serve a
different purpose from my own usage when
you have missing data as anyone come
across that before what's and why might
the circles be useful in that case wide
right so it might be that we see what
appear to be really two two weeks worth
of continuous inclined brilliant and
then when you plot those dots on it you
realize you've got two weeks with a dot
at one end and and dot at the other and
nothing in between
and actually this perfect trend that
you've you've noticed is just a drawing
aberration so and there was a low value
and a high value and no data in between
so we draw the dots and then when we've
got missing data thankfully we don't
have any here in this survey or the
dataset when we've got missing data we
can see all those data points being
rendered and we know we can trust the
data that we're looking at so when I
look at this I think oh there's kind of
a 7-day pattern going on here oh yeah
I'm pretty sure I trust that seven bit
pattern because it looks pretty
consistent and I've got all of my data
points
here we're changing the formatting
slightly adding a slightly nicer title
but it's the same chunk of data anyone
used the em date date formatter before
yeah how much success did you have with
it
yeah I'm still terrified of it because
it kind of works apart from when it
automatically decides to do something
else and then fun hours worth of
debugging ensues it's getting much
better as Matt Matt fought lib matures
it's already 15 odd years old but as it
matures into our different use cases
particularly into it a panda's
integration it's getting better at
rendering date time information but it
can still get a bit messy in a bit weird
at times that date time for matter it
was an addition to the library to make
it easier to dip inside the internals
and change the rendering options without
having to write your own functions so
you're just telling it the B and the D
I'm guessing that's a month on add a
signifier I don't know why it's %
lowercase B maybe that's a three letter
code for the for the months and there's
there's various string formatting
options you can put in there to specify
how you want those dates to come out so
kind of flexible
so let's group on week Dave and see if
things look a little bit different it's
like a group on weekday and then I
visualize it and then we get a really
obvious change of the weekend
it's kind of nice just we use in the
previous couple of lines of code and
changing the column that we're indexing
off of or using for the the group by but
it's not super nice to look at that week
they 0 through 6 so we can make a little
change we've gotten a cell below to map
those numbers 0 through 6 2 strings
which we can then use to label the graph
who's used the map function before on a
dictionary just to remap things just a
couple of you face good kind of a
powerful feature so you ask normally
with normally I'd use and apply function
and then apply with a lambda to take a
column and then apply the lambda to do
something I look up a value in a
dictionary maps really nice because it
just takes a dictionary and it maps
items into your dictionary by key pulls
out the value and replaces it so we can
run the same thing and then we plot that
and then we get a more interpretable
result and if we're telling a story to
colleagues we really want an
interpretive or results where they can
look at it and they haven't got to say
yeah decode for me what does that 6 mean
again you know you know it's the sixth
day in zero index so actually it's a
Sunday which you might think of the
seventh day we don't want that we just
want nice labels so matplotlib makes it
easy enough along with some pandas to
label everything anyone who's used it
for enough years knows that it's easy
enough but it's not perfectly easy any
covers a bit weird at times but you can
always solve it sometimes the past there
it's a little bit Wiggly but the pandas
integration is pretty good and always
getting better right listen for some
seasonality so and I'm going to zoom out
again so here we're using Seabourn
remind me who should see born before
okay so a handful of you
so the rest of you should be using
Seaborn seaboard really nice for not for
time series functionality it's got some
of that in there I use it mostly on mine
on time series data it's a bunch of
high-level statistical plotting
functions that build on matplotlib so
whereas pandas when I plot I can ask for
a box plot and I get a basic box plots
with seaboard I can give it some
different categories and say I'll make
me a number of box plots based on these
categories and then draw some extra
whiskers and other bits on there and it
just handles it for me and it does it
really nicely so I super recommend
Seabourn we're gonna use a couple of
Seabourn sharps next so what can we see
in this tell me a story about what you
see on screen here so this is using all
of the data ten years worth of data not
just the the single year we were looking
at before summarization is a bit
different we've got a box plot so we can
we can infer some things based on the
characteristics of that box plot I'm
really curious what do you see here
I don't want to tell you the story I
want you to tell me the story what do we
go
maybe a precursor question would just be
who is comfortable with box plots and
their interpretation put up your hand if
you are right all of you the hands up
start speaking what do we see here
right so that's one interesting thing so
on the the wind chart we've got what
looks like a standard box plot we get
the whiskers and then we get some black
crosses the black crosses are outliers
in this case defined by being more than
one and a half times the inter quartile
range away from the median so the
interquartile range on the the twelfth
column December that's the right hand
purple box the interquartile range is
the is the outside of the main box and
there more than one and a half times
that on either side anything outside of
that will be an outlier
[Music]
okay so the median is higher but then
the 25th percentile is lower further
away from the median than the 75th
percentile yeah so yeah at the weekends
in each of those months we have much
less usage disproportionately less usage
than we do for the other five days of
the week yeah so we see a box plot where
the median is not in the center but he's
offset telling us about skewness in the
data what else do we see what can you
tell me about the reliability of solar
vs wind what has lots of our lives
we're so your wind has lots of outliers
but Sol it doesn't so that's kind of
interesting so if I want predictable
power generation Sol is looking pretty
sensible we know the range is smaller
than it is for wind but it's more
predictable so I've got a better input
onto the grid for power generation with
solar than I do with wind but wind gives
me much more so I've got more
variability in the generation and I have
to do storage at that point and I
suspect yeah this is your area isn't it
maybe you should be lecturing this bit
if you want to know about the dynamics
and a generation of power in Germany
changes over from Germany and works
alongside these kind of data sets talk
to yemm's he knows all about this stuff
you can tell you about the storage and
the monitoring and the big data problems
around that I think also on the solar
side it's kind of interesting thinking
about the outliers on the extreme month
so in December typically we get a small
amount of sunlight so a small amount of
solar potential we don't ever have any
really dark days so we don't have
negative outliers it's not the case that
we have blackouts but we do seem to have
some very sunny days in December and
January so we have a couple of positive
outliers whereas it's much more evenly
spread during the summer months as you
kind of expect and then for the wind as
well yes we don't have negative outliers
but we do we do have days when there are
and there's little wind at all or maybe
no wind but it's never negative wind of
course there isn't but then there can be
some really really crazy powerful windy
days I guess big stormy events
what am I doing here so I'm using a
boxplot and just on the weekdays and
looking at consumption and so if we look
at the consumption spread over the days
of the week we see pretty consistent
patterns on Sunday and Saturday and for
most of Monday through Friday we've got
a very consistent distribution except
for those negatives outliers and as
we've suggested before perhaps those are
holidays it's kind of weird but we don't
really know but it's not the case that
on some Mondays through Fridays we have
positive outliers where there's a crazy
high usage of power so I guess I don't
have huge great industrial festival days
where everything gets turned on but
every now and again everything gets
turned off so we see this skewness in
the data
not a silly question at all it's very
important question thank you for
bringing that up
I didn't add in an extra parameter that
would have made that go away
and so it's a brilliant question so the
sort order that Seaborn uses it's based
on the discovery order so the first time
it found a consumption item would have
been on a Sunday in the data set
so it started counting from Sunday then
Monday baa baa baa there is a parameter
any one other parameter in Seabourn
offhand that let's use the place not
called sort
it's called order I think I think it's
Huw order and order and then you give it
the string of Monday through Sunday and
then it will print it'll display in that
order instead important question because
all these graphs always come out with
the wrong sequence that you want this
one at least came out in a weekly
sequence that was useful it wasn't
completely jumbled up but I think some
of the ones further below do and then we
have to do that sort and oh in fact next
couple of cells it turns out I wasn't
happy with that so order so so I supply
the order parameter that's what that was
coming up so I supply the order
parameter using that dictionary that
we've used before where I made the
dictionary in order 0 through 6 Monday
through Sunday so I take the values out
of that dictionary so I just get a list
Monday through Sunday pass it into the
order parameter and then my box plot
comes out Monday through Sunday instead
that's an important distinction for
dictionaries in Python version of Python
I think it was 3 6 or 3 7 that we have
now
dictionaries preserve their insertion
order it used to be the case that
typically you've got the order things to
inserted into a dictionary you would
extract them in the same order if you've
got the values out but it wasn't
guaranteed by the algorithm in recent
versions of Python it is guaranteed so
you can use it as a sequence in order so
you can use it for things like labeling
if you construct the dictionary in the
right order in the first place it's kind
of handy so let me get to that holiday
question
and I was curious this morning and so I
added this cell in just to see if I
could figure some of this out myself
I'll make this a bit bigger again so
here I'm saying for the daily data for
the weekday name of Monday generate a
mask take my data use square brackets so
this is a indexing with the mass and
pullouts
just the Monday's so I'm pulling out
every seventh day and then run a query
why have I not included that week they
name question inside the query which is
the question maybe you'll get a box it's
really Bernard reason why because it
would have been easier to write Oh PSD
daily doc query quotes week they name
equals equals Monday and consumption
less than 1000 and indeed that's what I
first wrote because of the space it's
really banal we can't have spaces in our
column names inside a query and I
followed the bug tracker on this this
morning a register on pandas but lots of
discussion around it the short answer is
we're not allowed spaces and this is a
bit more nuanced than that the the query
engine is rendering Python out of that
query string and so when it sees spaces
it sees non-standard syntax that makes
no sense and it would blow up the reason
that we aren't doing clever
interpretation on that query string is
that you rather than having spaces you
could have dots or slashes or colons or
semicolons which would have
interpretation inside Python as well
those things are all valid inside your
column names and so would have to write
a really sophisticated interpreter just
to get the query feature to work and
then when I read further into the bug
tracker it said and actually the query
feature was put up as a nicety we're
really the recommendation is we use
masks and it turns out in practice run
queries is kind of natural and writing a
mask is a little bit of a pain if you
think about it MIT more to make your
binary mask and so I think a lot of
people have adopted queries but then you
end up with this issue that you have
spaces in your names or dorsal columns
and then your query files with a really
messy error message so
I made a mask so daily masks lets me get
1/7 of my data just the Monday's worth
of data and given the Monday's with the
data
I run the query asking for anything
where the consumption is less than a
thousand so that will get me for this
Monday all these points here there's 11
of them and then I sort them by month
just so they they line up and we can
have a look at them and so for the
Monday's over all of my years we can see
a couple of mondays here so 24th and
31st so Christmas Eve is a public
holiday in Germany is that right and New
Year's Eve is as is New Year's Day okay
so your New Year's Day in the UK not New
Year's Eve in the UK so I'm right am I
getting that right around New Year's Eve
is no public holidays oh say that again
Ian's
yep but in the UK that's not the case is
it yeah okay right
checking good and so to support the
hypothesis the hypothesis that those are
negative outlawed low outliers that we
saw might be because of holidays
seems reasonable we can investigate the
data more this way and dig a bit into it
if we want it who's used autocorrelation
and lags before to look at patterns in
their dates er 1 2 ok you see something
noon good so one of the things with time
series is we hope that well depending on
the dataset we're looking at we may or
may not have patterns if you're a quant
working in finance you desperately want
to see those patterns and there's a
million other people around the planet
looking at the same data sets looking
for those patterns too and so finding
easy to spot patterns is really hard but
in other data sets if we look at the co
2 data set over the last hundred years
for the planet it's really easy it just
goes up and up and up and there's a
really obvious pattern and we can see
which way this is going we know that co2
production and storage in the atmosphere
is a big problem for the planet it's a
really really clear pan and we have to
do something about that so that's that's
a wider separate discussion for energy
generation we see a similar we assume a
similar cyclic pattern on an annual
basis we saw the energy Usha's being
higher in the winter and lower in the
summer and the same with our power
generation so some different patterns
there but they're cyclical so we should
be able to detect some kind of signal
coming out of this pan this has a couple
of really useful functions for this
autocorrelation is one of them this plot
is too busy so we're going to break it
down in the next couple of plots here
we're saying over our 10 years worth of
data for every data point look at how
similar it is to the point next to it
and also how similar that point is to
the point 2 points away and how similar
it is point 3 points away seven days
away 30 days away 365 days away all of
these things the fact that you see any
pattern here at
tells us there's something in here but
that's all smudged up and horrible we
can't really dig into that so we can
look at just say the first 30 components
and then we see something kind of
interesting that here's our weekly
pattern so we can also correlation a
correlation just looking at the point
today and the point in seven days time
so my Monday and the next Monday and we
see her at the 14 point so that's two
Mondays away it's pretty similarly
related to my current Monday this is
throughout all of the year my Monday in
two Monday's away pretty similarly
correlated my Monday in the next Monday
more so my Monday in for Monday's away a
bit less over still pretty strongly and
the same for Sunday to Sunday and
Tuesday the Tuesday but Monday to
Thursday or Thursday two Sundays with
the three or four gap kind of zero
correlation very little going on in
there at all so we don't tend to see a
pan just a few days away so if you do
this on your sales data or your website
visit data these kind of patterns come
out super clearly I was analyzing baby
breathing data with the NHS a couple of
years ago and you can pull out the
frequency of a baby's breath when they
were an incubator so when they've got
artificial respiration going on you can
see really nice patterns coming out
really clearly enabling really easy
signal detection so you can then
intervene and do things if you look at
the same data over 360 days so we've got
a year's worth and we can see that up to
about a hundred and sixty days so that's
half a year away my correlation even on
a Monday to Monday basis let's do
something there but it varies quite
widely and it's getting closer toward
zero but my annual correlation so Monday
to Monday looking at December to next
December actually pretty pretty good
pretty strong so it turns out our
consumption data annually over ten years
is pretty strongly correlated just all
over and over our winter to winter
Monday to Monday and whatever time
frames so we get a really strong really
consistent pattern coming an incredibly
consistent power I mean this is kind of
crazy leakin system
and a lag plot let us do something a
little bit similar so with a light plot
basically a scatter chart looking at my
point today and the point tomorrow for
all pairs of today and tomorrow and so
today is YT on the bottom axis tomorrow
is YT plus 1 on the y-axis so if my data
point today
looks like my data point tomorrow and
the data point after it looks like the
one after it will see some kind of
structure in this scatter chart some
kind of lines or wavy circles or
something with breathing if you're
capturing the flow of air you end up
with kind of a circular pattern if you
get a sine wave if you get a circular
pattern looking at this data set we get
comfortably streaky lines inside it I
don't know what they mean right now dig
into that in just a second but we see
some kind of pattern if you had no
relationship between the data on day one
and the dates are on day two you'd have
a random noisy field of random dots all
over the place and that's a really easy
visual inspection that lets you look at
your data and say oh there's there's no
relationship in here this is rubbish
so-and-so told me I'd find a really good
clear relationship in the day there's
nothing here
maybe my data's wrong oh heck I've got
some pattern in here and I can exploit
this what can I do with it so we might
ask ourselves what's going on in this
data set and is it the case that these
are these clusters represent different
things and we're building up to our next
exercise
so here I've said well let's take the
consumption data and let's take for the
C so that's coloring in matplotlib that
C argument is passed through like plot
into the underlying matplotlib function
and it applies C for coloring and I'm
asking it will take is weekend and
because we've got ten years worth of
data and the like plot looks at a point
to the next point
we've actually got ten years minus one
day's worth of data so I can't use ten
days so ten years worth of his weekend I
have to use ten years minus one day
which is why the minus one for the is
weekend colon minus one up to everything
but the last point and so I've said
color the points by is weekend so if is
weekend is true give it a color that'll
be yellow and if this weekend is false
give it another color
that'll be purple so we see two straight
we see a Saturday and a Sunday of course
we do and it means that the the other
streaks those are kind of those two
patterns those two oscillations we saw
on the consumption shards we don't quite
know what it is at the moment we can
take a pretty strong guess but then what
is at the moment and you're gonna check
that for us so we can look at this and
think great we've got some structure
we've got some daily structure coming
through in the lengths the time series
reflects days and weekends we could
exploit this we could do something with
this and a modeling context so remember
that we had week days and week names
that's just to remind you which columns
we had there and then here's your
exercise can we do the same thing that
you have before it's the same thing that
we had up here but not coloring by is
weekend but coloring by week day by week
day that's the easy one
so the question is do we see daily
structure in the data during the working
week is it the case that that's a bunch
of purple points they have before
they're just little smudge together or
are they actually streaked by colors by
those days do we see some finer
structure in there
so you can probably guess what the
answer is can someone interpret what do
we see for coloring and I'll give you
their the clues to what the colors mean
and using the very disk color map that
scales from purple 4 0 so our first that
we have before and now it's the index of
a Monday is 0 by some damn storms that's
bad just low number up to a six will be
colored for yellow so that's the highest
value in this case so zero through six
purple through yellow so what do we see
I mean do we see daily structure during
the working week is it was smushed
together or do we see streaks of color
that seem to be self-similar yes or no
mmm streaks of color any other votes
restricts the color okay
several question come any one time tell
me why we like the various color map
it's yes you know what that means so it
does something interesting to our
perception of a color map was there an
answer over there right so with the old
default jet color scheme the one that we
had super familiar with and was
inherited out of MATLAB that one was not
it didn't have a linear mapping of I
think it's intensity over the values
being displayed so some parts of your
color range appeared to change rapidly
from reg to Blues very quick color
changes even though the underlying
linear numbers we were looking at didn't
change rapidly another part of the color
space appeared to change very slowly
even though the linear numbers are
changing at the same rate the various
color scheme is perceptually uniform so
we should all and it's important to note
we should all even with our color
deficiencies perceive a more or less
similar thing much better so than we
worked with the old jet color scheme
doesn't work people who have probably
colorblind or have interesting
colorblindness is I have a
minor color blindness minor color
blindness I forget the name of it either
red red green I think minor inability to
distinguish colors so if you give me 7 a
not a tryptych but a seventh each of
seven color pieces about three of them
look very similar to me
and it would mean that if I look at this
kind of thing I think I can see the same
thing that you can all see but we don't
know one in a seven men and wanting
knowing women perceive the world a bit
differently according to this color
deficiency in our vision it's a thing
wired into the eyes we can't do anything
about it and then other groups of people
have other color deficiencies and some
people only see monochromatic lights
only see in black and white and so
various makes it easier for most people
to see what's being expressed better and
that's why it's the default inside the
matplotlib now and also it renders
better in black and white so when you
print things out there's a better chance
that you can see differences that are
expressed in the grayscale okay let's
move on with a B tutorial so date range
we'll get to some resampling now we're
going to change the frequency of our
data and look at some rolling means so
we can make date ranges something I
mentioned back at the beginning
so here I've asked for date range 2004
September 20th 8 periods our leaves that
we start with one day and then we work
through eight hours on that one day and
you'll notice that that date time index
that's been output there's a frequency
that's specified H hourly frequency so
we can see how it was generated if we
look at our data that we've read in
we'll see but there's clearly some kind
of frequency inside our data but the
frequency is set to none that's because
we read this data in it wasn't generated
by pandas we don't know what its actual
spacing is so we might enforce upon it a
particular spacing
and so what happens if we want to start
resampling our data and changing the
frequency of things we'll start with a
simple example
I'll take three days so a date time
three days in 2013 and I'll use those as
indices to index into our energy data
and pull out the consumption column so
we get 2013 Oh - OH - oh three and oh
206 and oh 208 so three days will be
some gaps in between and if I ask it to
resample or sample with the different
frequencies so not just with the
intrinsic data that we had but to sample
at a specific frequency I want daily
frequency it makes up the days that we
were missing in between Brillion only we
haven't got data so we get Nan's natsu
beryllium so filling in those Nan's then
becomes the you next question what do we
want to do the better answer is always
to go and find the true data and fill in
what's missing often we can't do that so
one of the ways to do it is to fill in
based on the data you've got available
and here for example we can do a forward
fill and so when we do an as frequency
the change the frequency of our data we
can say the method is forward fill or
backward fit or there's other things we
can do so what we could do different
things it in this case well it depends
on what we want to get out of it so when
we have when we're filling things in the
same as when we're filling in missing
data anywhere with we're lying in some
way and we have to make sure we're lying
in a sensible way so here I'm saying
those days in between we're going to
forget that we didn't know what they
were and we're gonna say that they're
the same as the day behind us when we
last had a good value or we could
interpolate or we could say over the
future value dragged back in time but we
have to know what it is that we're why
we're long so there's different answers
always but the nice thing is we can fill
in something so we can get something out
of this so here we're going to down
sample our data so under columns I've
got resample up here I'm going to re
sample with the W so that's a weekly so
I'm going to take every seven-day period
not a rolling seven-day period but every
seven-day trunk
and I'm going to sample that with the
mean down to a single value so I'm gonna
get a single weekly value for each
seven-day contiguous chunk of data
there's kind of a coarse way to look at
my data and summarize it down and I'll
get 1/7 of the data that I had before
and so I do that for a set of my columns
and then I get my weekly sampled data so
for a visual storytelling we know that
there's a pattern in the weekly data
maybe we've told our daily data patterns
to our stakeholders and have you want to
look at the bigger pictures so then we
can start to draw some compound graphs
here I've taken a subset of the data 20
1701 206 so January to June and I'm
taking out solar and I'm taking the
daily data those are the blue dots I'm
going to be those points showing us each
point that we've got and I'm taking the
weekly sample data that we generated
before drawing that in orange and then
we see that the weekly sample data looks
like the daily their daily actual data
it follows it pretty well and then in a
moment we're gonna do a rolling mean if
we've got little mental exercise for you
if we've got a seven day rolling mean
and we've got seven day resampled data
will the results be the same when we
draw the graph will it be the same some
of you're shaking your heads can someone
say why it wouldn't be the same
right so that's say if we do a seven-day
rolling average we maintain our days in
the first place we lose maybe the first
six days because we lose that first
chunk of data to generate the first of
the rolling averages but after that yes
we have our daily data and what about
the integration of signal change in a
rolling average versus a weekly chunk
yes and I think typically we could say
it would react faster if there's a quick
change in the week than rolling out
which would catch it on a daily basis
whereas the weekly average if there was
a big positive and a big negative change
and then he went back to the old values
that weekly average might just take the
big positive and negative and the other
values and squash it to nothing whereas
the rolling average will go away and
then down again and then back to normal
and we'd see something in the pattern so
if we generate the rolling average for
the rolling mean I should use the
correct terminology average is in
specific mean is specific I want the
rolling mean so the rolling generates an
intermediate data operator like the
group by that we had before and then we
can do things with it so we might say we
want the rolling median or the rolling
minimum we have the rolling mean in this
case it's the same interface is to group
I want to seven days and centred is
false so when I generate a mean I could
say I want the mean of this looking
forward and behind a certain number of
days I'm gonna be doing certainly any
machine learning analysis typically we
don't want to look into the future
looking into the future is bad because
if tomorrow I'm trying to predict what's
happening
I can't look three days into the future
depending on the data analysis we're
doing with that breathing data with the
NHS that I mentioned I had a full data
set and we didn't care about looking
into the future we cared about the
quality of care being given after the
fact and so the question was given the
data can we come up with good models and
so we could do a moving average that
integrated future and past events to
smooth things out and that was a
reasonable thing to do but typically
when predict in the future we can't use
things that are happening in the future
that we don't know about yet so I'm
saying sent it equals force
and then to generate that rolling
average the first bunch of days that go
into the rolling average we get a noun
so previously twenty two thousand six Oh
101
we had consumption data now we lose it
for the first bunch of days so we can
generate the seventh day moving average
and then if we combine these onto that
plot again now we get in green the seven
day rolling average overlaid over that
orange and you can see that sometimes
the orange and I'm looking at between
twenty 1703 and twenty 1704 the orange
kind of goes up in a nice gradual
fashion but the green the 7-day rolling
means is shooting up and shooting down
and then coming a feeling so it reacts
fast so it gives us a better quality of
signal detection or change in underlying
signal in this case okay yes very close
to the end now you might be running
perfectly at a time so let's do a bit of
trend observation so now I'm going to
generate a 365 day rolling average this
is over our ten-year data set one year
rolling forwards combine these into a
nice plot now we see a composition 2006
through 2018
that's 365 day moving rolling mean is
the black thick line it starts a year
into the plot because we had to
integrate the first years with the data
for the 365 mean and then after that
okay there's some wobbling in there but
it's pretty static over the course of
the year the 7-day rolling mean reacts
much faster of course it's seven days
and so it's going up and down very
quickly and in the background we see
those gray points and this leads to
another observational question what are
we seeing here but there are some odd
negative spikes going on it's quite
clear that some years more energy is
used other years less energy is used on
an annual basis certainly there's a
weird negative spikes or snow spikes
they appear to
late December and so that's not just the
the Saturday Sunday effect that's
something happening around Christmastime
really big relative to the rest of the
usage change so we can start to tell a
story with this dig in with our
stakeholders go through what this data
means try to understand I don't have any
observations about now and I don't I
don't understand actually yes
do you have any observation about this
consumption data for Germany for energy
Christmas times or December 31st that
rough period of time and also different
years in that decade there's been some
wide changes is there a story you might
you won't know about or I might just put
you on the spot okay so other public
holidays around Christmas yeah okay yeah
okay and what about the the significance
so this appears to be downturns in
energy usage some years and maybe it's
reasonable to say that some years were
unusually warm and so the winters
weren't as cold maybe I don't know if
that's we're not putting in more data
it'll be hard to draw any good
observations but we could form some
hypotheses to go and dig further into
what the data is telling us okay if you
pull in the solar and the wind data now
we get to see on this normalized scale
that solar the orange line is really
really small in generation capacity
relative to wind how we can see the wind
is increasing at least in this data set
quite dramatically in recent years
kind of interesting
and then you final exercise before you
get to break and wind down for the
evening what is our share of green power
over the years so the share of solar and
wind relative to overall consumption
you're going to have to calculate a new
column to do this divide you've already
got solar and wind as one of the columns
and you've got consumption as a column
together divide them together and that
will give you a percentage a ratio and
then we can graph it so that should
final exercise and then we can wrap up
but you can't escape until you've done
that
yeah
well now you're asking a tricky question
so if you're using the C parameter to
colorize and the colors come out how do
we label it typically for a continuous
range you can add a V bar and you'd have
to do a Google for that you had a bar on
the right-hand the normal way of doing
it slide a bar on the right hand side of
an image of V bar which shows the color
range over your minimum to your maximum
values and in Seabourn that comes with a
bunch of your plots so I think it's
called a V bar and if not I'll find it
with you afterwards I think yeah V Bar B
the one you need right let's solve this
exercise and I'm gonna copy in my notes
so I'm going to make a new column which
is called wind plus solar divided
consumption it's all just in quotes so
it's just a valid name and I'm going to
take the annual wind whoops
take the annual wind plus solar column
and divide it by the annual consumption
column so dividing wind and solar divide
by consumption to make a new column and
then I take that new column and I plot
it and actually I'll just plot it oh
it's a good question
ah we could I was just using annual
because that's what I had here but yes
it could use the daily yet yeah you're
right there's two sets we could use here
so here I'm using the annual just
because I can summarize percentage of
green by year but you're out could use
daily completely so here we get a line
chart coming out of this just kind of
informative we don't see the points on
here and it's a chart that goes up into
the right which is nice it might be the
case that we want to use bars in here
slightly clearer story perhaps and then
maybe we'd want to put some axis limits
onto this and so if I take I take this
and then we'll just try to this out
so that X takes rotation zero that's
because the label ticks by the
matplotlib default get rotated so
they're facing up rights and I've turned
them around to their flat again and then
I've turned at a funny angle we've set a
title I've changed the Y limits to be a
little bit greater than what it was
before just to give a bit of padding it
was up for about point two seven before
now we get a wire label at zero point
three on the y axis so we can read all
the way to the top and see what we've
got and I've only used data from 2012
onwards not going back the first couple
of years when we didn't have all of our
wind and solar if I get rid of that's
2012 we're gonna wind up with I guess
yes so here I've used : to say oh all of
the all of the rows and this particular
column but for a bunch of the rows I
didn't have wind and solar data so I get
Nan's
so I end up with no data so it doesn't
look so pretty
so instead I put in 2012 2012 onwards
and then we can see a nice a nice simple
consistent story that over the years
we're seeing an increase in share of
power consumed in Germany at least under
this log data coming from wind and solar
production anyone have any problems with
that any questions around that No
so we're going to conclude in that tire
case just in time for the break so I'm
very happy that around perfectly two
times thank you for playing along with
me with the exercises and the discussion
points I always prefer tutorials that
are a bit more discursive I'd like to
know what you're thinking and how it's
working so Panthers is really good it
gives us lots of the basic functionality
that we need Seabourn gives us great
statistical plotting on top of the
standard matplotlib plotting which comes
for free inside pandas anyway the
Seabourn builds upon it and I really
recommend you check that out and do some
more things with Seabourn if you want to
go further with time series analysis
particularly time series projection
there are various techniques but the
profit library from library P ro Phe T
from Facebook is really good out of the
box it has a bunch of algorithms in
there which do sensible time series
projections with error bars and it tends
to just work and so unlike messing
around with erima and area Max and a
bunch of other techniques profit
generally works reasonably well as a
first pass and it's very customizable
afterwards so I super recommend that if
you haven't come across profit
there's definitely way more you could go
into the time series around time zone
handling
thankfully pandas handles a lot of that
for us and if you want to do things like
time series decomposition to really pull
apart annual monthly weekly daily trends
then stats models has a nice time series
decomposition module which will take you
further ok I'm happy to answer questions
afterwards thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]